well welcome to the TR 20 to the next in
spectators regular series of video
interviews with fascinating Westminster
figures
I'm Isabelle Hoffman the assistant
editor and spectator and I'm joined
today by Michael Fallon the spectators
Minister for the year and business
Minister and Energy Minister
welcome Michael thank you so which the
two departments that you work in would
have would look the most different under
conservative only government oh that's
pretty hot answer I mean certainly
certainly at the business department I
hope we would have made employment law
are not easier and simpler just making
it easier for people to get on the
employment ladder by removing all those
restrictions that make people small
companies nervous about taking on any
single extra member of staff that they
actually need so you think the Lib Dems
have maybe left the labor market less
but more gummed up then you would have
liked yes we would certainly have liked
have gone further certainly for people
starting at there for their first job or
whatever there are far too many people
actually who are now working for nothing
as interns
well actually they should should be able
to get that first leg on the ladder what
sort of things help them well they are
they really do they really need the full
panoply of employment protection and all
those kind of rights were they're just
starting off and on energy how that the
department at different imagine it would
look very different given some of the
public roles that have taken place well
I think we inherited from labour
essentially an energy policy that was a
climate change policy they had signed up
to all these various targets to have
really worked out how we were going to
get there I think if we'd be if we'd had
a free heard from 2010 I hope we would
have been more focused much earlier on
making sure the two key things were
there that there is enough energy to
make sure the lights don't go out and
that is affordable and just moving on to
Europe more generally how would you vote
if there were a referendum on our
membership of the EU tomorrow well I
voted yes last time I'm not sure what
the question would be if it was tomorrow
but given we've you know we've set out a
programme of the reform
we would like to see and you'll see more
in the manifesto obviously I hope we can
get a reformed Europe that we can live
with but it's going to have to be quite
different to the one we have at the
moment so it's going to have to be much
less bureaucratic much less coercive
modernizing centralizing it's gonna have
to get away from all that and be output
looking liberal you know genuinely
competitive for the rest of the world so
you must personally have your own list
of things that you really like to see
reformed in the European Union or within
our relationship with you or there any
to you could share with us well I'd
certainly like to see our employment law
and social protection I'd like to see it
made easier to employ young people it is
a scandal that we have six million
people under the age of 25 in Europe I
think the 17th largest but the state if
they were all put together who have no
work at all
maybe the Mediterranean countries and we
have to make it easier for small
businesses to flourish in those
countries and to employ people and how
much of this detail of the Prime
Minister's shopping list would you
expect to see before the 2015 manifesto
is published so in the next few months
before the European elections after the
European elections are you hoping for
for more meat for for conservatives to
see what's the PM would like to do yes
we've already set out some of the
perimeter things we'd like to achieve
and the problem is really achieved quite
a bit he's got the budget leg down for
the first time ever and has shown how
you can block laws in Brussels and by
exercising the veto but so we've also
been conducting something called the
balance of competences review reviewing
every area of legislation and seeing
what further powers we can bring back
and that is the kind of meet I want to
see in the next manifesto well there
many of your colleagues were very
unhappy with what's been published so
far in the balance of competences review
day so it is a sort of year a far
whitewash which said that everything was
fine in Europe we didn't need to reform
anything do you recognise that
description
well it's department by department isn't
it I hope you know my own departments
have made it clear where we're not so
happy where we think there is too much
legislation whether it is a case for
bringing these things back to the to the
Member States so you need to look at it
department by department but that is
what it will be new at the election
we'll be setting out
the the about that we want to repatriate
to where it lies
how about how you deal with you kit
what's your what's your plan you came I
think we need to front up to you kipper
you know not run away from that we need
to take them all on their own arguments
are you running away from them at
moments no but I think you know we have
to engage them properly I don't think
it's enough just to say they're
completely batty or whatever I think we
have to front up to them take them all
all those central arguments and ask them
you know where they expect to be if we
were suddenly leave what the plan is you
know who would we join up with what
would our trading relationships be you
know what jobs are actually at stake you
know you don't have to be you know you
don't have to be a mystic or
pro-european to see that leaving Europe
isn't quite that simple that I think we
do to you know challenge the policy by
policy so is the party not doing enough
of that at the moment well we have to do
know in the run-up from not only to the
European elections because they are
always you keeps time so you know this
is the time that we should be doing it
okay well Michael fun thank you so much
for joining us we'll be back in the new
year with another tea at 22 episode
thank you